imagine that we have a crystal ball  let's try to look into the future and  imagine how technology will develop in  2023. this year more and more countries  will introduce a digital identity card  paper is becoming a thing of the past  biometric verification will be  introduced everywhere perhaps as soon as  this show your password for your laptop  will not consist of a string of symbols  and instead use your voice or the iris  of your eye the crypto industry will  become even better regulated all around  the world for example in Switzerland  they are already bringing in identity  verification for transactions of more  than 1 000 Swiss Francs most likely soon  will commence the Battle of artificial  intelligence we'll see programs that  create deep fakes up against programs  that are able to spot these deep fakes  and tell them apart from real people so  what do you think What new technologies  will we see in 2023 share your thoughts  in the comments